hélas pour atteindre les séries si vous
vous appelez jeanne et que vous habitez
à côté du studio vous venez bien sûr et
vous aurez une tablette à gagner plus
vous continuez #cannes bien sûr je vous
appelle et vous dites je vous dis jamais
vous dites au secours il ya une tablette
qui part on passera des coups de fil
tout à l'heure pour l'instant c'est les
questions en 4/3
moi je suis explosé j'avais vu leurs
esprits comme ça parce que je veux que
vous sachiez que j'ai trop j'ai dansé
pendant j'ai dansé mais je crois que
pendant la pause mais c'était à rien
s'est lâché on pourra voir une une
serviette ou tchétchénie bah oui mais
n'importe quoi dans les malles à bord de
quads mer c'est salue le suédois de
l'équipe
alors raconté elle est tout de suite une
question si vous voulez une question
bonjour je m'appelle marie france quand
mon chien voix cyril hanouna
il se frotte de plaisir contre la jambe
de mon mari donc je voulais savoir
comment cyril fait-il pour être aussi
populaire
merci aussi à merde c'est une excellente
question que vous posez là marie france
car son ex chéri est un véritable
phénomène
il plaît à tout le monde il est
populaire auprès des 15/34 les ménages à
moins 50 mais aussi auprès des chiens de
moins de 17 ans tout le monde aime syrie
les six normales mais si c'est normal
qu'avec un car il a tous les talents
on connaissait l'animateur le danseur
mais depuis peu on a découvert
l'imitateur donc limité bon il faut
encore un peu bosser les textes
kenzy vient nous rejoindre formidable
kadji kadji sur le canapé rouge fait
bouffer que kenji
quand je t'aime que je t'aime
ça va les motards saluent les loups
bienvenue dans vos poches
aujourd'hui il ya eu du rififi loulou
autres les candidates the voice ya john
kevin qui a pas voulu bouffer le coup de
zazie je me voyais déjà en haut de la
fiche ça va les petits lampions
sa valeur
juste tous regroupe il a souvent envie
d'aller aux toilettes c'est ça tu vois
c'est bien construire l'intérieur
franchement ça c'est beaucoup pour les
artistes mais nommer une carrière qui
s'ouvre devant vous vous rendez pas
compte mais bon là dessus du créateur
siliana ckoi actuellement c'est surtout
la chanson avec la sortie de la copie ne
touchent pas amazigh et notamment la
reprise d'une chanson de khaled oui j'ai
vu comment elle s'appelle achats je suis
pas sûr on va vérifier richard c'est
touche pas magique bien sûr c'est le
berceau haïtien aïcha comme si un gros
coup de mou tarik comme chez alain
bollery pulchra le truc
mais c'est pas possible
mais c'est pas possible laquelle ringard
n'hésite confie je pense à watari les
tunisiens lui
d'après notre monde donc c'est harry ça
mais bon le tube du moment c'est quoi
c'est cet hymne assez flippant bogda
bogdanov avec la musique ça passe mais
quand notre public leurs trois a capella
ça fait un peu secte
à
tu as beau cadeau
oui jean michel et eu du mal à intégrer
la chorégraphie on aurait aimé qu'ils
intègrent pas du tout hein parce que ça
nous aurait évité son bonus le bonus de
jean michel nouaille
lourds man c'est lourd c'est bien si
jean-michel n'avais jamais entendu cette
chanson ça nous aurait évité aussi le
deuxième bonus l'un d'eux c'est un bug
d'allonger ses pierres parlent de moi
mais sans qu'elle est méchante la mère
de son contexte évidemment sûr c'est
dommage que la connerie soit pas visible
sinon tant attendu en fin de troisième
chanson parce que ça crée aussi bien
chez toi comme moi j'accepte la vanne
cas car c'est vrai que jean michel est
très beau et qui peut se permettre des
vannes sur le physique alors sa beauté
c'est un fardeau pour lui ou en tout cas
dans sa tête car vous l'ignorez sans
doute mais dès qu'une invitée rentrent
sur le plateau jean michel se dit
qu'elle ne vient que pour une chose le
pechoux trespass de commentaire
milliards
mais
je suis
pareil
accor
le loup
a tapé do fé
m
à temps plein
oui
à voir samedi mais ne me regarde pas du
tout ce à quoi elle était là mais après
c'est vrai pas qui s'est vite réalisé
elle à éviter aussi les vaches et les
tables de 10 euros il m'a regardé
bizarre on va passer à la suite parce
que c'est dérangeant
maintenant c'est cyril et valérie la
semaine dernière ont discuté programme
télé à part pour cyril on sait le lundi
c'est quoi ces créances et les crimes
mais ça va si vous n'avez pas l'émission
il reste très ouvert la discussion
la chine ce soir à la cuisse et milady
ya théâtre ce soir octobre mais se
saurait et et atterrit à leur fille du
cac les trois couches de béton
vous êtes témoin vous êtes tellement
j'essaie souvent ma soeur pouvez jamais
les insanités j'aime c'est que ça passe
ou pas celui choses très étonnant nous
avons trouvé quelqu'un de l'équipe il y
va ce soir quand même c'est que le début
a quelqu'un de l'équipe qui aimait les
vannes de thierry moreau non un oui on
parlait d'un reportage sur les chiens
voilà c'est une émission de niche en
fait c'est pas marché suisse et l
attribution à volutes avait été super
d'ailleurs et c'est ça le problème
quelqu'un aime l'humour de terrines et
manque de bol c'était la chroniqueuse à
nîmes qui ne reviendra plus rien que
pour ça elle va revenir mérite un bon
tir et ne fait pas que des blacks dans
l'émission parfois il nous apprend des
trucs du tout
ce qui n'est trop liquide et l'on est
collecté dont il est dit que c'est parce
que j'ai pas est-ce que vous les femmes
ils ont regardé beaucoup c'est parce que
vous en pensez mais bon le recalé
cette même pas
bravo au lycée et c'est plus grand amour
entre les deux présidents ont une
nouvelle fois cyril fait beaucoup minex
avec qui avec battront chamerois pas si
regardez oui et camille combal reviendra
tout à l'heure je vous le dis à
aujourd'hui
voilà c'était votre troisième séquence
préférée ces procès propre saynètes part
oui enfin c'est surtout nettoyer hop
c'est ce qui passe à l'antenne car si on
remonte un tout petit peu en arrière
les lancements sont un peu plus bizarre
non ah oui
cavic obama devra tout à l'heure je vous
le dis à aujourd'hui alors ça lâche
georges fait massacrer
voilà c'était votre troisième séquence
une autre dimension à sa rivale savoir
cyril et bertrand aime bien se toucher
les parties avant de prendre l'antenne
on les comprends c'est tellement garde
de ce fait piquer ou qq donner du
courage mais et cyril bertrand ça ça va
un peu plus loin je ne sais pas comment
définir leur relation de soin de
personnes autour de la table de l'angola
à définir c'est pas vraiment un couple
il ya vraiment des étrangers c'est pas
vraiment des gens sains d'esprit elle
vous comprenez ce que nous subissons
pendant les pauses je vous ai fait une
petite compil de plus je t'aime bien ta
mieux maîtriser tout dure comme ça on
dirait une barre de fer
je t'ai dis un truc j'ai marché sur une
couille à quelqu'un il avait la trouille
tout plat l'accueil de jour à qui
aucune faille
je
kate kate qui était quelle tête
on y va direct parce que on doit finir
assez tout apport d'eau et tu l'a pas
volé tu l'as pas à voler dans ton cul
c'est le genou c'est le bon sens mais
benoît c'est génial
ah oui on vous laisse faire tout ça
belle attaque qui a trait au volet
physique on est tellement heureux de se
voir ça tu en voilà zizi peu de
paillettes
bah oui bah voila merci et enfin
toujours aussi créatif cyril inventer un
nouveau jeu pour la venue de lilian le
vainqueur de ce voice un service ce
garçon quitte et fromagers chanson en
fromage l'arrivée cyril et bien oui mais
pour une fois série ne va pas
complètement assumé le jeu et donc
d'être assez hésitant pendant les
explications pour que ce soit moins
gênante j'allais passer au ralenti en
mode bourré j'ai peut-être un truc
peut-être dans 5 rue vous devez voudrait
faire quoi dans c'est quoi
mais ce match même ce que c'est a promis
je pense à un truc en fait c'est
remplace une chanson par un fromage
non messieurs vous attendez un petit peu
la récente union parce que je dois je
voulais pas le vexer et ben vous vous
aurais pas dû accorder sa réaction parce
que ça m'a beaucoup fait rire ça c'est à
vitesse normale
j'ai peut-être un truc c'est peut-être
lancer un truc voudrait voudrais faire
un nom mais quoi c'est quoi
l'imbécile malice que cet après midi
j'ai vu passer un truc en fait s'il
remplace une chanson par un fromage ont
balancé sur ordinateur on va lancer sur
twitter voilà hashtag une chanson un
fromage
après il est rentré dedans après
l'entrée dans away bah c'est pas de la
fromagerie
quand vous passez devant vous êtes
content quand vous rentrez vous êtes
encore mieux c'est ça exerce il embrasse
tous les fromages équipe bulgare en tout
cas comme l'émission passe mais au
ralenti et comment on l'a beaucoup
demandé sur twitter un nouveau numéro de
touche pas à mon bistrot
bravo florent pagny verso jury je suis
pas du tout d'accord avec enfin si
justement je suis d'accord avec valérie
à moi j'aime de plus en plus geeks
tournait en plus de plus amplement mais
je suis fidèle à les 12 coups de la
marche sont enfin alors que nagui c'est
trash au française qui s'exporte
est ce que dieu et ma chérie tu peux
nous lire le numéro un
oui ils ont préféré mais comme ça oui
messieurs l'aurait mérité un sobriquet
donné la france en entendu le bo fallait
tu as euroconnect elle est elle-même je
m'en fous qu'ils auront moniteur
elle même ses dauphins qui m'intéresse
et c'est long mais ça va pas les
dauphins que ce que toi tu sais
ce à quoi on adore de nos questions oui
bien sûr bonjour je m'appelle serge il
paraît qu'elle n'aura a menti en disant
que le magazine lui lui avait proposé de
poser nue donc comme ne sera pas publié
est ce que le pourrait envoyer les
photos à poil directement chez moi je ne
peux malheureusement pas répond à ces
questions ça ce cas je ne sais pas si
ces photos existent mais par contre je
sais à quoi vous faites allusion la
semaine dernière dans une interview
nabila pour le magazine lui le directeur
de la rédaction frédéric beigbeder avait
fait une déclaration qui depuis a été en
prise sur je ne sais pas combien de
sites je le cite
enora a raconté qu'on l'avait proposé la
couverture de lui mythos complet je suis
heureux de pouvoir rétablir la vérité et
nora ne fait pas partie de la longue
liste des femmes célèbres qui ont refusé
la présence de lui voilà ça a été repris
par tous comme si c'était un sujet
vraiment important alors est ce que les
noirs et mito évidemment dans l'équipe
tout le monde le sait et c'est pour ça
qu'on aime bien mais c'est pas grave
parce que nous devons la vérité
le magazine lui va bien consacré sa une
à quelqu'un de l'équipe
non si mais bon pourquoi choisir un
chroniqueur qu'on peut directement
touchés les seigneurs en exclu voici la
couverture du prochain numéro un
il sert il à une reddition paraguay
j'aurais préféré voir ce corps que le
bien voilà c'est ça quant à enora désolé
franic bbd a été bien clair il n'y a
jamais rien proposé alors calme toi bon
au cas où j'ai quand même été chercher
dans mes archives
je suis assez dernière j'avais hésité à
vous montrer des images
maintenant je pense que c'est le moment
j'en ai parlé à l'instant
d'accord elle n'est pas pudique est un
peu bourru
m
pendant les fêtes alors qu'à l'époque
j'étais avec un jeune garçon que de
killer donc ça m'étonnerait merci jean
luc oui mais voilà des mois qu'il avait
insisté après en me disant je vais je
réussir est bien là convaincre voire
écoutez moi j'aime beaucoup prairies que
j'aime beaucoup et non océans mais des
techs et ouais voilà je l adore il va
travailler merci la plus oubliée
bon si j'avais demandé à billag de poser
du fonds les méchants j'avais oublié
voilà voilà
et d'ailleurs elle avait refusé ma
chérie en tout cas si on m'avait dit que
c'est à dire l'honneur d'enora je serai
obligé de révéler qu'elle aimait bien
montrer c'est beaucoup dans les cercles
en tout cas c'était juste une petite
piqûre de rappel
c'est pas parce que c'est sur internet
que c'est forcément vrai voilà merci
oh